[Music]  I'm done having children so now I can  join the boys I'm excited  sixteen years after Kelly Clarkson won  American Idol she's heading to the voice  [Music]  [Applause]  Kelly will join fellow coaches Adam  Levine and Blake Shelton for season 14  airing spring 2018 she revealed the good  news while facetiming with Blake on  Thursday it's clear the competition is  on I'm coming oh come I'm a win  I am excited you know I can't wait to  serve you could just make it you just  make it through a year without getting  pregnant that would be great for all of  us so this retain not only our fans  excited for Kelly former American Idol  judge Harry Connick jr. is too the  singer had nothing but praise when he  spoke with et on Thursday at the Wizard  of lies premiere in New York City she's  like the perfect person to judge a show  like that because she knows from both  sides what it's like to have hits and  what it's like to be in a competition so  she's gonna be amazing  [Music]  you